The intent in this lesson is to give you a feel for how some enduring
concepts stand the test of time. The ideas in Quicksilver, namely,
using transactions as a fundamental operating
system mechanism to bundle and stage recovery
of operating system services. Found resurgence in the nineties, in the LRVM work
that we discussed earlier for providing persistence. Again, in 2010, it found
resurgence in the form of providing
safeguard against system vulnerability and malicious
attacks on the system. And another research operating systems called Texas. We
will mention Texas when we cover a later lesson module on system security.
What about the computer industry and the commercial
operating systems? Well, they always focused on performance.
Reliability always takes the back seat. You will
be amazed, what goes on under the covers
of an operating system to gain performance. Just
as an example, you write to a file,
and you think it is on the hard disk. Well, think again. It is a while before
your file write actually gets persisted on the disk. What if the system
crashes in the meanwhile? Well, too bad. Well things may change in the future.
There are new kinds of memories called Storage class memories, that have
latency properties that are similar to a DRAM and are yet non-volatile.
Will this new technology result in a resurgence of
exploring transactions once more in operating systems? Only time will tell.